que ce problème qui consiste encore une
fois à désigner comme ça comme on le
fait tout le temps des gens sous
prétexte qui sont des immigrés comme les
responsables du chômage
moi quand on est on va en parler après
si vous voulez sur la façon de gérer
leur situation en France il y a quelque
chose moi qui me fait un peu de la peine
si vous voulez ouais je vais vous
montrer quelque chose moi je voudrais
montrer cette photo l'adresse cette
photo là
c'est la reconquête de la France quand
ils sont partis de Corse
et qui sont montés jusqu'à Paris c'était
sur les Champs-Elysées c'était les
spahis vous connaissez ça vous vous le
connaissez
les tireurs marocains c'était les
Sénégalais alors voilà maintenant ce
qu'on en fait ces gens-là on en fait des
dessins sur Le Pen il distribue des
dessins avec attention à vous
l'immigration c'est des dragons qui
jettent le feu qui sont en train de
manger les petits Français
simplement l'immigration
parce que la nature de la France c'est
justement le contraire de ça